charlie morton meanwhile going for the
atlanta braves and he has degrom-like
numbers against the mets this year and a
couple of starts a 0.69
era alonso up to the plate oh one to
alonso
line drive right to freddy freeman and
on a knee
he squeezes out number three no runs
no hits no errors one man left we played
a half an inning
that's nothing now the braves coming up
when we come back
youngster tyler mcgill will make his
second
major league starts and he did so
against the braves his last timeout
ronald lacuna leads off
wasn't in the lineup against mcgill the
first time that
tylor faced them last week
and it's on the inside of a backup
slider from mcgill
to get acuna for the first down so one
out and nobody on now freddie freeman
but he had two of his hits in a four hit
game against mcgill
last wednesday and he goes down swinging
on the slider
and mcgill's got back-to-back strikeouts
on six pitches
to start the game albies like cucuna has
struggled against the mets this year
just four for 28.
in fact the braves as a team have a 178
average against matt pitching this year
and a back foot slider and this time he
went around for strike three and so
mcgill
strikes out the side on 11 pitches
rather than nine
quite a start for the rookie no score
after one stanzby swanson hitting fifth
in the order
and swanson takes a slider for strike
three called
generous call by adam beck and mcgill's
got his fourth strikeout
so mcgill with a chance to get through
the inning first and third and two down
and now the number eight hitter william
contreras
travis darno down for probably the
majority of the season
after tearing up his thumb and alex
jackson who was supposed to be his
backup has been out for most of the year
as well
so that's pushed contreras into the
number one spot
with kevin smith as his backup and he
drives one out to left center field
coming on is dom smith diving and he
makes the catch
[Applause]
dom got just enough of a jump now mcneil
who had a run-scoring hit
in last night's game knocking home a man
who was in scoring position
something mcneil's hardly done this year
here's the one-two pitch
it's a check swing for strike three it
skips away from contreras but mcneil
was walking back to the dugout that
secures the strikeout on his first
strike out of the ball game we head to
the bottom of the third inning
no score in atlanta a one-out-of-one on
for freddie freeman
who struck out his first time up good
battle going here between mcgill and
freeman this will be the seventh pitch
and he struck him out with a changeup
so mcgill picks up his fifth strikeout
as he gets freeman for the second time
door had that sack bunt back in the
first inning
got him to swing at that one and lindor
will be thrown out with a good peg to
first
and back-to-back strikeouts for charlie
who has set down
ten straight two down for dominic smith
who's over one with a ground out
one-two pitch got him looking strike
three
fastball takes care of dominic smith and
the mets here in the top of the fourth
inning
three strikeouts now for morton in the
ball game no runs one hit no errors and
none left we had to the bottom of the
fourth inning
mets and braves scoreless in atlanta
mcgill has turned in three scoreless
innings he's given up a hit and two
walks
over the first three striking out five
riley has the hit
a single to right center in the second
seventh pitch of the back coming from
mcgill to riley and he struck him out
with a slider
six strikeouts now for tylor mcgill and
that's the first out in the fourth
dansby swanson took a call third strike
his first time up
one two coming to swanson and he struck
him out with high heat
tyler mcgill showing off all his wears
tonight he's got
seven strikeouts hit one off the end of
the bat
grounded out to freddy's first time
shipped on for pilar to the left side
the pitch check swing did he go
doesn't matter pilar's headed to the
dugout he didn't even wait for the call
he just spun around and headed to the
dugout strikeout number four for charlie
that was funny
james mccann slide to center his first
time
the wind in the 2-2 to mccann another
curve swung on a missed it was in the
left-handed batters box
backhanded by contreras he has to wait
for mccann to get to the grass and then
he's
rung up by back strikeout number five
for charlie morton three in a row and i
swear that pitch
in the left-handed batter's box i did
charlie morton grounded out his first
time up and he goes down on three
pitches against mcgill and this at bat
eight strikeouts now for tylor two out
braves trying to be the first ones on
the board
acuna at third freeman at first ozzy the
batter
he has really scuffled against the mets
this year four for 30.
swings at the first pitch and sends a
drive toward the braves
bullpen way back that ball is gone
over on ozzie on the first pitch three
to nothing braves
on a rocket out of here by ozzy albee's
his 13th of the year scuffle no more
against the metro
vendor has put down a sacrifice button
first and
struck out in the fourth no balls two
strikes for the met shortstop lindor who
sacrificed and struck out
and he just struck out again on a
breaking ball he has gone to his knee a
couple of times and charlie morton
carves him up that's six
michael conforto singled his last time
up
on a fastball 97 he had a rocket back to
center
and a swing and a miss conforto couldn't
catch up to the curve ball back-to-back
strikeouts again that's seven
charlie morton is grounded on struck out
over two
one two coming from drew smith and it's
hit back up the middle
lindor behind the bag able to snag it
and he throws out
morton to end the innings and now the
mets will get the tying run to bat on
the seventh with james mccann coming up
one two coming to mccann and he lofts
one to deep left center field back in
the gap goes radia at the wall
it's on here james mckinnon ties the
game with a three-run
homer the mets get the big hit they've
been looking for
seventh home run of the year for mccann
and this game is even
three to three in the seventh ms lindoro
for two and a sacrifice
and lendore cracks one base in the left
center field and that'll bring home the
lead run
perazzi into score francisco lindor with
a big two odd hit
and the mitch laid it 4-3 in the seventh
they've got
albert almora up there here's the 1-0 on
the way
round ball out to dansby takes it on two
hops to ozzy for one ozzy to freddie
double play and thus the braves are down
to their final out but they've got
ronald acuna jr coming to the plate one
for three and a walk tonight
and he pops the first pitch up into
shallow right field
in comes conforto out goes peraza
conforto makes the catch of the ball
game is over